i think donald rumsfeld is one of the
most evil human beings to ever walk the
face of the earth and i find it
hilarious
that i marched against no blood for oil
in college and now dick cheney and and
the cheney's are team biden and now
everybody on the left in america is a
war hawk
you know how how thing times have
changed in 20 years blows my mind you
know but
in your estimation and you're passionate
about this and first of all thank you so
much for your service and i'm ha i'm
glad a guy like you is on our side
how do we you said that the economics
are unsustainable the economics of
imperialism are unsustainable how you
you have to decimate an entire country
then you have to occupy it for
generations
you you know so the
the concept of going in as a peacekeeper
and setting these places up
you don't you america we we the
revolution we didn't beat britain we
just outlasted them we made it we waited
until it was unpopular enough at home
and they were like these are our cousins
let them have the place the war of 1812
they came back and kicked the [ __ ] out
of us and then thank god napoleon got
got antsy and said i'm gonna fight
otherwise we'd still be british again
and then vietnam over and over and over
the economics of imperialism unless
you're gonna go in on some von klauswick
[ __ ] and just mow everything to dust and
start over you can't do this anymore you
can't fight these wars they're
unsustainable which is why this
commission is so important right because
we have to fundamentally change how we
go to
and come home from war right and if we
change what we're going into
and we have a different end state in
mind right all right you just described
it perfectly for too long our end state
has been the world war ii model we come
in we beat you
right we're now in charge
you like the japanese and the germans go
along with it and don't fight back
how often does that actually happen
right by the way von klaus which is how
we win world war ii we we basically
steamroll both of them right when we
actually drop atomic weapons on another
country
that's how we get these people to
capitulate
every other example that you there's a
profit incentive well
that's again that's what we have that
you're right the economics of
imperialism don't work
the way that we go to war doesn't work
uh and it needs to it needs to be fixed
this can't happen again what was the
very first thing that biden's new uh
secretary of defense did he gave a 250
million contract to raytheon right who
did he work for before he was secretary
of defense it's a revolving door how's
that okay
it's not
we're supposed to have ethics laws in
this country there was
there's supposed to be a more a ban on
you know lobbying and everything but
again as you pointed out the rich and
the elite and the powerful get to have
special privileges do you think that
ever goes away yes how
no but but your strategy where you're
going to
do do you think this ever goes away show
a time in history yeah that's gone away
uh
marie antoinette would say it goes away
okay the
the powerful can only
sustain power
for as long as the powerless agree that
they're powerless
right especially domestically i've never
in a million years would have thought
that you could shut new york city down
for two years and the new yorkers would
go along with it i never in a million
years growing up in that area i would
have never thought that people would be
like you know what
yeah
you know i i'll go bankrupt it's fine i
don't mind yeah whatever whatever it
takes i know that this doesn't make any
sense wearing masks six feet apart you
know the the bums on the subway they're
they're walking around doing everything
you're telling everybody not to do and
they're surviving for years but no i i
whatever whatever you say de blasio in a
million years i would have thought there
would have been a riot i would have
thought there would have been a
revolution i would have thought there
would have been people you know tarred
and feathered and ran out of town on a
pole
and it's not happening anymore it turns
out you know they said the pen was
mightier than the sword the camera phone
is mightier than the sword bed the
camera phone is the most powerful weapon
ever created people are are are so
afraid
to
you know
and and i think the problem pat becomes
in this moment you you talk about law
and order a lot then this moment it's
such a dangerous moment because the only
people that are making any sort of
positive moves are the type of people
that have absolutely no regard for the
consequences of law order criminals
autocrats you know
what this is really going to be for
people looking back at this 500 years
you were talking about 14 19. people
that are writing about this time they're
going to say
democracy may be a great idea but as
long as there are
autocrats and dictators you may not be
able to sustain it so there's a guy
named benjamin barber who wrote a book
called strong democracy back in the 90s
and basically what he argues is that
that there's there's there's a
progression of democracy that that
coincides with the progression of
economies right so economies go from
agrarian to industrial to
post-industrial or what we would call
basically creative economies right and
we're in a creative economy um we're
post-industrial britain's
post-industrial um
korea post-industrial japan's
post-industries
um
neil pagley has talked about this a lot
where this is where androgyny comes in
well so what he argues though is he says
that that the sort of the harmony state
of of that we all grew up thinking of
what capitalism and nation-state
relations and democracy should look like
is the post-world war ii environment
pre-true globalization what he basically
calls is like the
the 50s and the in the 60s
and what he argues there is that before
you had transnational corporations
economies had companies that were based
only in the united states right you had
you know disney was just an american
company ford's an american company right
so they're subject to american law and
if they want to do business there they
follow american law they don't really
have to worry about i said no though i
mean coca-cola made fonte to sell sugar
water
that's but that's where he gets the
point is once you have he argues that
once you have transnational corporations
once capitalism expands they on the
borders of the nation state
transnational corporations actually
become the most powerful entity on the
planet right because they're beyond
government regulations hard to argue
with that okay so what benjamin barber
argues is that the only way to actually
reel in the negative effects of of
rampant runaway capitalism which we have
robber barons now that's just
corporatism it's not really capitalism
global federalism
no yeah no
it's the only and i'm gonna be honest
with you i think that's where we move as
a species
that's what they're that's what they're
trying no the idea the idea look
you have on your list here this crap so
the problem is government so we need a
more giant global bureaucracy
you have to think of it you're thinking
of as a one government like u.n thing
and i'm talking about more like the
united states of earth where xi jinping
is in charge of earth it's a
democratically elected thing okay
who's agreeing to that i'm i'm telling
you i think that's where we move to
jesus christ
there's no way the nations to if you are
fundamentally arguing for the nation
state which has been around since the
idea of the treaty of westphalia i think
at this point honestly you're running
you're arguing from a 20th century
mindset
we're beyond it we're beyond it we're in
something different disagree with you
we're we we're we are we are we are
i'm telling you right now this is where
the human race is headed whether you
like it or not this is where i i
guarantee i i predict within 100 years
you think there's gonna be a common
language within a hundred years i don't
know if we're gonna be common culture in
a hundred years we're moving towards one
no we're moving towards we're we're
moving toward
capitalism pushes us this way no stop it
does gosh capitalism pushes it why the
efficiency the efficiency of being able
to do the efficiency of one there's no
way listen let me ask you a question how
long are you going to tolerate if i slap
you on the back really hard how many
times how how often do if i keep doing
it too right if i get up right now come
to your back and i just start slapping
your back really hard how many times can
i get away with it probably once okay
that's what i'm trying to say to you
right but let's just say you're like
your first reaction is going to be what
what's the matter with you right stop
but you're first going to say what stop
if i do it again if i do it again you
and i probably brawling over here right
okay
i don't think uh i think the history of
mankind
you've always had people
that are driven by power and control and
you've had people that are driven by
freedom
and leave me the hell alone okay
one group masters the art of
manipulation
the other group masters of art of
persuasion the strength of those that
are driven by power and manipulation is
they
sell their concept more because they're
better at bitching and crying and
complaining
because they have more time on their
hands the weakness of those who are
driven by freedom leave me alone is
they're so occupied building something
creating something winning for them and
their families they don't have time to
[ __ ] they don't care too [ __ ] they're
not going to go out there and try to do
anything to you but if you sit down with
them and you have the ability to reason
you can they can persuade you and say
here's why i live my life this way right
if the person's willing to pursue you
know be open to it now
historically go and look at um
religions many people will say
most religions were created to control a
populist let's just say i'm a christian
some will say you know that is a form of
you know the ten commandments to get
people to not do anything to each other
you know don't do anything to a guy's
wife and don't murder and don't do this
fine you take a hundred different
religions and you put the structure
together but 90 of it is what similar
things you're not get to pick and choose
you want to be a christian presbyterian
you know whatever you want to be
similarities right there jewish
christian pretty much the same thing
christians have one other guy that came
afterwards and they think he's a jew
christians think he's a jew christians
think he is the messiah right okay
but
the ability to want to control isn't
anything new the difference is
people are a little bit more not a
little bit more wiser today the negative
side of it is we have a million and one
distractions today that we didn't have
before this is the ultimate distraction
that we have today right so where am i
going with this here's where i'm going
with this um
i don't think
you know i think there's a point where
you can't push people that are driven by
freedom too much i think if you cross
that line you're going to see a side of
theirs you've not seen before i think
that's kind of the direction we're going
right now people are rising up you're a
guy that voted for biden you go up
against them you're willing to come to a
podcast like this and have a
conversation and we go back and forth
and the people that win today is the
audience because the audience sees us
having differences we're having this
discourse and they walk on and say screw
pat screw man screw gerard or dude
gerard's my guy i agree with him i wish
adam was here pat's wrong whatever
they're going to do but the audience is
winning right now right so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]